good evening everybody and welcome to
this District planning committee meeting
held on Thursday the 16th of February
my name is councilor Kevin Lagan and I'm
the current chairman of this committee
members we're streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you're giving
your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I will
then invite you to do so at the
appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore can
I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
please reference a page or a paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible but
covering the issues that you wish to
raise
Ironton number two is apologies to
absence Verna could I please have
apologies
he may be running late and we've also
received apologies from Kansas
boys pound and schemes
thank you Berna thank you move on to
agenda item three uh these are the
minutes of the last meeting is
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 2nd of February 2023
found on pages 7 to 12 of the gender
pack are approved as a true and accurate
record ISO move do I have a
second-development motion counselor none
seconds that any members have any
matters that I wish to raise on the
minutes
no members reapproved them by Ascent I
agree thank you minutes agreed please
thank you item number four which is
Declarations of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other registerable
interests and non-registerable interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda have in regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members members a reminder they should
also require to disclose any such
interest as soon as you become aware
should the needs arise throughout the
meeting do I have any Declarations of
Interest
no members love you thank you very much
indeed I have a
non-registerable interest that's to do
with the Malden salt which is a product
I've used all my life but I want to make
it very clear and transparent that I
have that that interest
indeed but I just feel I should do that
as chair of the committee
okay members we move on to a gender item
five which is item application two two
zero zero eight three seven slash
f-u-l-m slash CML Microsystems limited
oval Park Hatfield Road Langford this is
found on pages at 13 to 18 of your
agenda pack uh Miss herner um would you
like to present the report
thank you chairman so this is an
application for car parking and upgrades
to surface water drainage system the
application site Falls within the
um allocated employment site known as
oval Park which is allocated under
policy E1 of the local plan it also
falls within the chelmer and Blackwater
Conservation Area
um and there are a couple of listed
buildings
on the edge of the site over here
and so just to give you some context you
probably all aware that the four
applications on the agenda today
um are part of the wider over Park site
so the application before us at the
moment is considering
um this area here which also includes
the access roads for some car parking
so as part of the wider plan
it's also proposed to uh bring forward a
sewage generous use here and here so
these are gender items number seven and
number eight
so in order to facilitate these
developments um a car a new car park is
needed to serve the existing employment
site which is here and then what will
happen is the two existing car parking
areas either side of that building will
then serve the new employment uses
and and then this area of the site over
here is the outline application which is
a gender item number six
so essentially
um
the the car parking as part of this
application will um then depend what
happens with the the other two
applications that interrelate
so just to provide um some contexts
where we put in an aerial photograph
just so you can see the context of the
site at the moment so it's this area
here that the the application relates
and just to the front of the existing
building
so here we have the location implant
down at the bottom and the block plan so
you can see the existing access forms
part of the application site and then
it's proposed to put to extend the
estate Road around to the side of the
building and put some car parking area
in here and then also six parking spaces
along the front
and so here we have the
tree um plan so this is the existing and
the trees that would be impacted so
um there is a
small section of a tree group to be
removed to facilitate the construction
um and then additional planting will be
placed around the sides in front of the
building
so this just shows the proposed layout
again so um still has a potential amount
of landscaping and then additional
Landscaping to despite the loss of those
trees
so this is the surface water management
schemes just to show there'll be some
permeable Paving and some infiltration
crates below the the car parking area
oops
so we have some photos of the access
um this was taken from the lactate
visual impact assessment but it just
shows a good um panoramic view of the
site access
this is the site access within the site
and then looking across the employment
building so I hope this gives some
um
context that the fact that the the car
parking will actually be cited behind
this building
um so any views from within the site
itself will be very limited and it'd
only be experienced by those actually
within the car park itself
and so this is the
back of the building where the car park
would be so some
tree
line boundaries
um and yeah the rear of the employment
site so this bit here would be the hard
standing and this is taken kind of
standing where the the tree line begins
and so this is a Viewpoint
um looking North to the rear of the
sites the car park would be tucked
behind the existing tree boundary and
wouldn't be visible from anywhere really
outside of the site
so the development was not directly
related to employment itself would
facilitate additional employment within
the wider site which would help to
achieve the council's economic economic
Prosperity aims and therefore the
principles considered acceptable as I've
said the position behind the existing
building and Boundary vegetation limits
the degree of harm to the character
periods of the area and the conservation
area to an acceptable degree and due to
the distance and intervening vegetation
and buildings there's no harm to the
listed buildings
the hard surfing surfacing will be
um to the rear of the site will consist
of a
um sort of sealed gravel surface so it
wouldn't just be a harsh tarm Act
surface
there would be no intensification of the
existing use as a result of this
development on its own so in no
neighboring impacts in that respect
and and so you're probably all aware of
the members update that were circulated
that recommended the removal of
recommended condition five this was
initially imposed to ensure that
development couldn't commence without
the need of the other two developments
coming forward however the condition is
now not considered to be reasonable or
necessary as it has been dealt with by
other means outside of planning and the
harm is also not considered great enough
to Warrant the condition and would also
impact on the ability to secure economic
gains across the site so
um the reasonableness relates to the
fact that the degree of harm on the
character and periods of the area and
the conservation area being so limited
so yeah so that the application is
recommended for approval thank you
chairman thank you Turner um we do have
one public participant Mr Nick Davey
who's an agent Mr Davey if you've done
this before haven't you many occasions
so if you'd like to find your way
through to a microphone
uh there's a fair one over there
thank you
when when they the little Clock of Doom
up there starts counting down then um if
you start there you have two minutes uh
precisely to to
um to address the committee thank you Mr
Davey uh thank you members um you have
before you this evening applications
from three successful local businesses
CML modern Sultan technique that
provides for the comprehensive
development of oval Park in a manner
that will safeguard and bring new high
quality jobs into the district
and we'll help the council deliver its
economic Prosperity strategy
the proposals will secure the
development of this strategic employment
site in a manner that is entirely
consistent with local plan policy E1
we send a date to the site for
employment uses including General
Industry and generous employment uses
um today is a combination of lengthy
pre-application process that's included
meetings with the parish council and
local residents
and these applications have been with
officers for a year and we've uh during
that time we've met and resolved all
statutory Consulting concerns
um the proposals are brought forward of
four separate applications so that each
can get off the ground as quickly as
possible if consent is granted
mood and salt and technique both have a
pressing need to expand and will
purchase their development plots and
build the buildings themselves an
outline permission is also thought to
develop the remains of the site as a
prestigious business and research and
development Park
this application the first one in a way
it's key to the whole scheme it seeks to
provide replacement parking for CML as a
land upon which its existing car parks
are located will become part of the
modern sort and technique proposals so
if this position isn't granted those
other two schemes can't go ahead
the application also includes proposals
to upgrade the surface water drainage
system which was installed in the 1990s
at Sears oval Park so that it meets
modern standards rainwater will now be
held on sites for reducing flood risk in
utling Lane which should be to the
significant benefits of the residents
your officer has summarized all the
planning issues so I'll just finish by
saying that my client is happy with all
the conditions and we hope you can grant
consent
thank you very much indeed Mr Davey
perfect timing thank you
um members I just just refer back to the
members update that was sent out to you
earlier as Miss hernan's just reminded
us
um and I now invite any members who wish
to comment uh councilor Stevens please
thank you chair
um I've just realized that all my page
numbers are going to be addressed
because I've made my notes before the
minutes were inserted so you'll all have
to just do a bit of arithmetic because
it's beyond me sorry
thank you very much Miss herna for your
report I think it's very clear and most
of the questions I previously had I
found were answered as I went through it
so that was great
um I've got a bit of a concern about
removing this um condition about the car
park
um I do get why we would do that but we
could end up with giving planning
permission for the car park but then
refusing the rest as this evening draws
on and I wonder if we should or if we
can make a condition that is that the
car park is conditioned upon the other
planning applications being approved I
don't know if we can do that
Johnson I was wondering if you could
help us with that please
but thank you chairman I mean this is
something that we have discussed um
within it within within the office
um
it
it wouldn't we wouldn't be able to put a
condition on of that nature
um each application still has to stand
on its own
um this application however is
considered in its entirety and while
there are
Elements which rely on each other the
car park supports other aspects of the
development as a whole
um and we do appreciate
as wide as part of the wider
conversations we've had there are legal
agreements in place between the various
parties but in addition
um there is
um and Ms hurler can remind me exactly
where it is there is condition which
which does prevent the occupation of of
of of of some of the other sites on this
application
um before the car park is in itself
um developed and brought forward such as
the interrelation between them
um and and I think as the as the the
agent for the Appling has also mentioned
um if the if the if the car parking
application is is refused it would have
an impact on the other application
because it would effectively mean that
they wouldn't meet the car parking
standards
thank you chairman thank you very much
Mr Johnson
Council Stevens
thank you I really wonder if we ought to
be looking at this application after the
others then but I'll plow on with my
other questions
um there's much reference to trees that
have to be filled and replacing them I
maybe it's because when I enlarge the
diagrams that the whole thing just
pixelates but I can't see numbers I'd
like to know how many trees are going to
have to be filled and how many will be
replacing them or a ratio so we might
say that for every tree that's got to be
filled three or four more might be
planted or something like that
um I was a bit alarmed to see a
statement well on mine it's page 21
um that the trees that to be filled are
to be screened or are screened from
public view so they've got a low amenity
impact well yes but the immunity impact
on the ecology it's not just about what
you look at so I was a bit surprised to
see our agriculturalist saying that
anyway
I'd like to see a condition around the
ratio of felled trees to replaced trees
and on the occupation on mine it's page
26 it says the soft landscape Works have
to be carried out in the first planting
season after occupation and I'm not sure
what occupation means with the car park
and why we can't just say it must be the
first planting season after the
permission is granted please thank you
thank you councilor Steve's um from my
perspective we're sticking with the
order in the order papers published I
don't know if Mr Johnson would want to
maybe comment on the other point that
Council Stevens has made
sure
okay so in terms of the specific
um numbers that don't have that to add
at the moment because it's a tree group
but there would be a net biodiversity
gain across the site and
um sufficient tree planting
as confirmed by our tree officer to a
replacement planting
um
in terms of the ecology as well so all
the necessary back surveys and
everything have been undertaken on the
site to ensure that those trees won't
have any detrimental impacts on ecology
thank you very much thank you uh
councilor none please uh thank you very
much
um I can see the logic of the
application and I note the officers
recommendation to approve can I take you
to
5.8.1 on page 26 uh which won't surprise
you to learn uh chair is about
archeology uh and um it talks about
disturbance
and it and it there's a very odd
statement that says it's unlikely that
there'll be any archeology present
because the ground's been Disturbed well
the very nature of archeology is
disturbance
and what I find surprising that this is
obviously the expert's view is that the
other three applications although we're
taking these in isolation the other
three applications have got
archaeological conditions on them and
they're on the same site
and Langford is a particularly sensitive
area for archeology and I just wonder
why we've ended up with
recommended archaeological conditions on
applications six seven and eight but not
on five
thank you
thank you thank you chairman so the
recommendation was from the historic
environment officer at Essex County
Council and I think it's to do with the
the way the site has been used
historically and as you've pointed out
but and then
yeah I think just based on the expert
evidence on that
that's the start to be taken and any
condition that we'd need to impose would
need to be a pre-commencement condition
that would require agreement before we
can impose it on an application of this
nature
um
application
I'm grateful for the response chair but
do I take that to mean
that we could only impose the condition
if the county archaeological section
said there should be one
that's okay
impose one um just as yeah as the expert
on the matter that it's their advice
that we've taken in respect of the
recommendation so I don't know what sort
of depths we're talking about with this
landscaping and car parking but I would
personally like to recommend if this is
approved that there is a condition uh
similar to the other conditions thank
you okay thank you and cancel the White
please
um thank you chair for letting me speak
um well I have to say that I don't know
how many years ago I went on to a site
visit to CML and those of us that
attended were all very impressed with
the work that was going on there and we
also did a site visit to mold and salt
at the current application site and in
fact I supported their bladder for their
salt unfortunately it got turned on my
members and was and wanted appeal and
for me these are iconic
companies they are on a business site we
need to promote jobs we need security we
need to promote the brand of molden
because really for me these are the
brands of molden so yes there might be
some ecological harm I can see the sense
of putting an archaeological dig onto
the car park if if members so wish to
put that condition on but I absolutely
think I agree once Mr Johnson that we
absolutely should support this
application in fact we should welcome
any incoming investment with open arms
because this is absolutely what we
should be doing and I'm delighted to see
this application come forward so I'm
happy to propose that we recommend the
officer's recommendation or agree the
officer's recommendation thank you uh
cancer what is that with the sorry just
to make that sort of follow-on Point
disregarded sorry to make a following
Point regarding the the condition
um
any such archaeological conditions
suggested by a council number would be a
pre-commencement condition the
legislation requires that
pre-commencement conditions are agreed
with the applicant should the applicant
not agree with the pre-commencement
commission condition if members are
minded to approve this application with
such a condition we'd have to come back
to committee for us to then take on
board the fact that there is this
particular condition so we will be in
that position
I would withdraw the suggestion of an
archaeological degree then I'm happy to
propose that we accept the officer's
recommendation thank you okay just as
that seconded Council Swain
yep okay just hold on a second I've got
lists of people first up you're on the
list counts of swine thank you uh
councilor Morgan please yeah thank you
chair
um there is considerable local concern
uh what effect this is going to have on
the Malden and traffic on the Malden and
Langford roads which is already pretty
bad
um and I was just wondering what
um
investigations are going to be just what
sort of level of commercial traffic's
going to be visiting the site in
particular large trucks Etc and there's
going to be particularly exacerbated
when we the a12 widens and because the
only way back onto the a12 from there is
going to be worthy Duke of Wellington's
roundabout which is already a
considerable traffic deadlock uh I'm
just wondering whether officers have
properly looked into I mean obviously
it's not highways as necessarily their
concern but I think that is likely to be
a considerable difficulty thank you
thank you
thank you so
it is something I'll come into as part
of the other applications because with
this application and there isn't
actually an intensification of the use
of the site because it's just a car park
to facilitate what's already there
um but the ease your concerns early on
there has been a full transport
assessment undertaken and that has
looked at priority Junctions
um there's six of them and it's also
factored in North haybridge Garden
suburbs
um South modern Garden suburb as well
and the um expected impact from there
and they're expected to be some modest
increase in traffic at the Junctions and
waiting times but nothing that's
significant significant that would
weren't concerned but that is something
I'll address for the other three
applications
thank you very much indeed Council
Darren please
yeah thank you thank you chairman
chairman I mean this site is in both my
district Ward and my County division and
and members as councilor white has
mentioned that there have been numerous
applications for this site in the past
committed by CML
um predominantly to include um housing
on the site and they will refuse both
here and ended appeal
um this this is a really important
commercial site it is an employment site
that was the main reason for not
granting uh housing on on that site and
I think we'd almost given up hope due to
the economic climate that there was
going to be a commercial use brought
forward really pleased that there has
been these RS has been mentioned
Landmark companies CML is an extremely
uh important
high-tech company operating globally
um and we all know about Morden salt
um and you know
all I can say Germany's at long last we
have an application for this site that
is going to fit in with its original
uh intended use because there was always
going to be more commercial use on that
side it just in since the site was
envisaged uh so this is only where we
intended it to be back in the day when
the original application was granted so
yeah I I you know I appreciate there may
be concerns about traffic but I'm sure
they've been addressed but you know that
this
this is to be welcome for the prosperity
of the district and and um and The Wider
country thank you
um thank you very much indeed uh
councilor Swain please
uh thank you chairman
um two things firstly um
is this
um the reason perhaps for the
distinction here on the um
archaeological side is if this is
essentially concerned with car parking
it's much more superficial and uh less
intrusive than when you're developing
new buildings and drilling right down
um so you know it may be rather like the
Leicester which is the third situation
um but it would be uh would be nice if
um they were to do a quick run over the
area with a geophysical survey to
um see if we can identify if they
haven't done this already to identify
um whether there is anything significant
there
um that should be a fairly
um fairly cheap and a quick um exercise
to do and I don't know whether we can
put that in as a condition perhaps
um on the question of traffic I I
totally agree this is a very welcome
idea of the hot development of a whole
place
um and the the question of traffic is
really about highways one
um to get them to do something about
access to the a12
which is going to be an increasing
problem with North haybridge Garden
suburb but from a point of view of
General access
um and I'll perhaps come back to it in
another one whereas mentioned about
um public transport
um it could be a very
um well-served site by public transport
and I
will follow that up really when it
perhaps it's been more relevant later in
terms of
a provision of
um lay buys from for buses and so on uh
to service the site and foot ways to
connect to uh well the North haybridge
Garden suburb as well as the
um bus stops thank you thank you uh very
much indeed Council Swain I think
there's more comments and but pressing
off the Elder won't be under there
um he's hearts in Ely I think and uh I
think we've got much chance of that
um councilor Hurd please
sorry Gem and I was previously raising
my hand to uh to Second something but
it's been second I think councilor Luca
was after me no okay cancel that thank
you very much councilor fluka yeah thank
you chairman I I mean I know you
mentioned vinyls but don't forget that
Richard III was found in the car park
yeah but I don't think I think we knew
where Britain
I mean look we didn't know you know
going back to what members have said I
mean the sequence of this is dealt with
quite clearly in the members update you
know there's a members update on why the
car park comes forward first and and
clearly that makes that makes sense
um as far as the bore a cultural is
concern I mean again our own tree
specialist is quite happy with this and
I don't think anybody likes to see a
tree cut down but when it comes to the
immunity they clearly can't be seen by
anybody I'm not saying that that is a
good thing
um as far as archeology is concerned I
mean clearly members have got some
concerns about this but the archeology
people at Essex
so I don't know whether we should hog
tie us with this I mean if you look at
the condition that's going to be
hopefully applied to the next
application we're going to consider
which is on page 77 you know it's quite
a big decision I mean my initial thought
is is that when they built the offices
at oval Park they would have Disturbed a
lot of the land there as well
um you know it is a very very tricky one
and as far as highways is is concerned
Essex County Council as the local
highways Authority have no objections so
we can't do anything about that Gemini I
think there was a murmur when
um councilman White made her proposal
but I'm happy to support it German and
but I I would like a little bit of
guidance from Mr Johnson regarding
archeology you know I'm quite you know
I'm quite comfortable about it based on
what Essex have said uh but I think one
or two members aren't but I don't want
to hold up this application because you
know as councilor down says you know
I've been involved in this site for
about 12 years and it's you know it's a
marvelous thing to see it come forward
not as a hybrid and we desperately need
employment land developed in the in the
district thank you
I've pulled up the full response from
the um historic environment officer so
the reason is there's been disturbance
associated with the site's use of the
Water Treatment Facility in the southern
half of the development area so they've
said that it's unlikely that the
archeology that's known to be present on
the northern part of the site survives
in the area of this application and
that's why they've not recommended any
condition so hopefully that clarifies
the point a bit better
thank you very much
Mr Johnson and uh just to add to that um
if um a scenario came about as was
mentioned earlier you know the
applicants don't agree to the condition
it comes to us and members feel they're
in a position to just say refuse the
application on that basis uh obviously
Define themselves in a very difficult
position in defending any soft position
on any appeal if that were the case as
we'd have no
grounds on which to defend against one
of our own technical advisors on a
matter of you know some specific
detailed and Technical matters thank you
chairman thank you very much indeed Mr
Johnson my members um we've had quite a
thorough debate on the matter
um we've had a proposal by councilor
white which was seconded by councilor
fluka up just before we move move the
motion
and
so thank you for listening to me on on
page 23
5.5.1 it said about the um pedestrians
and Cycles an appropriate horse ride in
routes I'm sorry to keep harping on but
you know just so that you remember there
are horse riders and we don't want to be
left out again thanks no thank you very
much indeed for presenting that and
you're quite correct uh councilor Mays
my apologies
yeah thank you Mr chairman um
my my question just revolves around the
the permeability or the not permeability
of the car park
um why
uh it's been chosen to be non-permeable
because then you don't get run off
therefore you don't get large amounts of
water splaying all over the place
um perhaps you could give me an
explanation on that bearing in mind on
other parts
um of the application and other bits it
does actually go for permeable
surfaces to the car Parks which to me
would be a much better
idea
um so that's the first question the
second question
um is what is happening to the existing
car park which I think is to the east of
the building I know it's not within
this particular bit but obviously it
belongs to it at the moment what is
happening with that is that staying
there to then be hived off or is there
something else is it going to be
expanded thank you
I'll start with your easy question first
so the existing car park and there's one
here and one here so what the the mold
and salt application that's on gender
item seven will be served by that
yeah existing car park and then the
technique application which is it gender
right some eight um will be served by
that yeah so that's why there's the need
um in terms of the drainage I won't
pretend to really know the answer to the
actual Paving itself will be permeable
and then it will go into these
infiltration
um crates
I don't know the reasoning behind that
um but the studs team at Essex County
Council have been consulted and they're
content with it there is a condition on
there and for further detail to iron out
all the details prior to it okay
please
I know that um you know you're not
interested in um flooding elsewhere but
there is severe flooding in alting line
that occurs on a very regular basis and
obviously if you've then got another
load of water adding to that you're
going to compound the problem
that already exists thank you thank you
very much indeed thank you counselor um
members so we did have
um the motion to approve proposalings
which was seconded and we also had um a
comment by councilman about a further
condition I think if we'll put the
original motion and the recommendation
forward if that fails then we may look
at a second
um notion councilman
no I don't think my condition was
seconded was it really
so uh no I don't want to impose the
condition thank you very much okay thank
you Council and for clarifying that so
members would you like to agree this by
a cent or
that's obviously very clear that that's
uh recommend to approve thank you very
much indeed
thank you members
okay we move on members to agenda item
six which is application two two zero
zero eight four one slash o u t m oval
Park Eastern plot Hatfield pevel Road
Langford that can be found on pages 39
to 82 of your pack and again it's Miss
Hannah to present
location with access for consideration
and the use will be for a business and
Research Park with a new estate Road car
parking service areas and Landscaping as
part of the application there's always
always also highways upgrades included
and which relates to the improved bus
lay buyers on Hatfield Road a two meter
wide footway link from the site to the
bus stops and a dropped curb Crossings
and a possible possible amendments to
the 40 mile an hour speed limit and
enhancement of the peak hour bus service
during between Mondays and Fridays for a
minimum period of three years
so just to show you the overall site
layout again so this part of the site
that we're talking about at the moment
so in terms of how this relates to the
other applications there's an overflow
parking area and which will also be
available to the other developments
um
if and when it comes forward or when
should I say
um and then an aerial photograph so you
can see that it's um there's a lot of
vegetation and quite heavily
a lot of scrub Landing here at the
moment so these trees here um are
subjects of a true preservation order
um which I'll talk about more in a
moment
so here's the location and block plan
this is the existing and proposed tree
impact so the you see a large proportion
of this vegetation is to be removed as I
say there's a lot of scrub in there as
well and and some of the protected trees
are also to be removed
um
so only a few of the trees including the
protective trees are actually considered
to be a better quality and again they're
screened from larger view so our tree
officers has raised um no objection
subject to the submission of a
protection method statement
so we've got the indicative layout so
you have
so it's it's outlined so this is
indicative
um the road here will actually form as
part of this application as well so this
will actually be brought forward and
because access is a matter of
consideration the the layout will
largely be dictated by the roads
themselves anyway
um
so it's proposed to phase the
development so there might be a
requirement to bring forward all four
buildings at once if they're um if it
comes forward as Reserve matters to be
built that way so what we're actually
suggesting is conditions to phase the
development to ensure that for example
if this one building comes forward there
will be sufficient Landscaping across
the site so we don't end up with a half
finished site
and you can see lots of car parking and
suitably screened by the buildings and
lots of areas of public open space just
open space
um
it's part of the appeal decision
um on the one of the previous
residential applications the inspector
talked about how it's important to
maintain the Parkland character of the
site
um and how actually bigger buildings
rather than individual plots of
residential development will be able to
do that because you'll have bigger
buildings but with a more open view
through the site so
um officers opinion this although
indicative sort of layout would maintain
that
so here we have the
surface water management strategy so
again permeable hard to add in into
infiltration crates um we've got some
filter drains and a swell
this shows the highway upgrade so
um pave in to the bus stops and drop
curb tactile Crossings
again the photo of the slight access
the access within the site and then
these are
photos taken from within the site so as
I was saying lots of dense scrubbling
not necessarily high quality tree so
just taking you back to the sort of
we're in this part of the site it's not
easy to see from the photos
and then this is looking towards the
Alton Lane boundary to the East and then
looking North across the side to just on
the outside so
um
along this boundary and those photos
were taken within this part of the site
a narrow photo again myself there so
here's some viewpoints taken from this
is from the landscape visual impact
assessment that was submitted and so you
can see
a Viewpoint would be looking towards the
development would be behind these trees
here so densely
screened boundary with vegetation
a similar Viewpoint again
this is the corner of Alton Lane where
obviously Lane meets Hatfield Road
and then from within Ultra name itself
so you've got the corner here so the
development would be set back
um with public open space here for
people using the site
and then
the air condition suggested to ensure
that the buildings couldn't be greater
than two-story so limited visibility
from behind the dwellings from Alton
Lane as well
so the
um distance from the listed building
means that there wouldn't be any harm to
their setting a significant setting or
significance there's a low level of
lessons to some substantial harms to the
conservation area which triggers the
need to carry out a plan imbalance but
it's considered there are significant
social and economic benefits that would
substantially outweigh that harm so the
application would bring forward 200
full-time employees and with policy one
seeking 2000 jobs over the plan period
they said they'll be highly trained and
skilled employees it would bring growth
of within the aims of the Malden
District economic Prosperity strategy
and within their growth sectors it
should attract new inward investment
increase average gross weekly take-home
pay across the district
it's allocated land so it won't impact
the loss of other land uses and it would
also involve improvements to local
transport Network which will not only
benefit those within the employment side
but they're nearby residents as well and
of course help climate change for
reducing
um car travel
there is of course some disadvantages
such as increased vehicle movements but
a transport assessment has been provided
and it's been found that it'll be fairly
limited time in that respect
the parking requirements are also
considered superbooks has been extensive
surveys carried out on existing staff
and that would use a wider site and also
tricks assessments things like that
there's also the proposal to implement a
work Trace workplace travel plan and
that has aims to reduce car travel by 10
over five years and
promote car sharing things like that so
a real push away from
private vehicle usage the upgrades of
Highway Network can also be secured by
way of a condition in a section 106 is
currently being prepared to secure the
monitoring and checking fee for the
travel plan
we can restrict the hours of use to
protect any residential immunity but
this is an employment use which is
considered to be
um acceptable in residential area
and so for those reason offices
recommend approval subjects to the
conditions in the report and to the
section 106 bin
signed thank you thank you misana again
um Mr Nick Davey the agent who was just
to speak
thank you Mr Davis so when again once
you start the clock starts going down to
the two minutes thank you yeah thank you
again members
um this is the only part of oval Park
which is as yet no identified end user
but we think the best way to attract
tenants is to take the site to Market
with an outline consent that
demonstrates both the landowners and the
council's commitment to the projects and
we think with CML already on the site
and with modern and modern tools and
technique under development this plot
will be attractive and firms will want
to come here to be part of this
concentration of successful high-tech
local businesses
uh the submitted details show how the
plot can be developed for a low density
research and business park in a manner
that retains the vast majority of the
original Waterworks trees it's
interesting to know that the majority of
the vegetation shown on that plan is all
self-seeded in the last 15 years
um and we can create a with some
additional planting a very attractive
Business Park set in Parkland setting
as your officers are concerned without
respects the immunity of neighbors and
the character of the Conservation Area
it incorporates a full surface water
drainage system within the site which
will make sure that runoff rates are the
same as a green field
and we have demonstrated archeology and
then sorry and that archeology and
ecology matters can be fully addressed
with the development delivering
biodiversity net gain both on and off
site
it will also deliver a package of public
transport improvements that have been
agreed with County highways and it's
worth pointing out that the conditions
attached to each of the three main
applications provide that those
improvements were delivered from day one
you won't have to wait for all three to
come along they'll be delivered
whichever one skin goes ahead first
so this plot can deliver up to 200 good
quality well-paid jobs and sectors of
the council is targeting as part of its
economic Prosperity strategy and the
grant of outlines consent will be a
significant step forward to securing the
development of this last remaining part
of oval Park thank you thank you very
much indeed Mr lady thank you okay so
members just opened the floor first um
councilor stilts please
notice on this report that we have got
some trees that have got tpos on to be
removed they are going to be replaced
aren't they
questions and but what I would say is
proposed to be a high quality
development so as part of the reserve
matters we could look to ensure in
things like that and I think that would
likely come forward in the future
thank you very much indeed uh Council
redwoods please
thank you chairman um
actually I I sort of found the answer
in the break but I was going to ask
about the public transport
um
I understand it's the 73 going into more
than from
off that road
but it's a two hourly service but I've
just found on page 43 that the to
argument the existing bus Transport
Service achievement hourly peak time
between seven o'clock in the morning
till 10 o'clock at night sorry at 10
o'clock in the morning and three o'clock
in the afternoon to seven o'clock so the
two hourly service is actually going to
be addressed by one hourly service which
I just found but I'd just like to point
out in one of the applications
uh they start at five o'clock in the
morning in terms of working so I just
want to point that out thank you thank
you very much indeed councilor white
please
um thank you Mr chairman I mean just to
sum up with um I think the concerns have
been answered and in likes my comments
about the applicants and the companies
that want to be here I'd like to propose
that we agree this recommendation as it
stands as it's a very welcome addition
to our district and we should be proud
of these companies
chairman now all you have to do is
replay the take for what I said of the
prior application thank you very much
indeed and I'll gladly do that
um Council Shaughnessy please
um thank you chair
um I would just like to reiterate um
counselor stilts has said I mean
scrubland is very important and I don't
like it spoken about as though oh yeah
we'll clear it away and that's that you
know I I realize the site must be tidy
um but and you also have to be careful
of what planting is done you know if you
just plant anything it's not going to
bring a biodiversity back I just like to
make that point and and scrubland is
important and also the solar panels I
mean we've got massive roofs here they
should be flooded with solar panels why
are they not why is that not in the
proposals I really would like to know
that thank you yeah but I think it's
Reserve matters is it so that's it okay
perfect please
yeah thank you chairman and I just you
know I'm always always a little bit
cautious when I look at out playing
outline planning applications and in
this particular one I I perhaps if you
can put up the uh the site plan for me
I'm not I I did visit this site the
other day yeah I remember this past when
it's coming for us previously I mean
this is the one that has got the
Residential Properties to the uh like
looking at that would be the southeast
corner and also opposite
um look I appreciate that this this is
outline but I think the report is silent
um with regards to environmental issues
uh light noise pollution so
um what I wanted to be absolutely sure
because these things often fourth you
know they fall through the net between
the outline and the reserved
um whether or not this will be addressed
through the reserve matters application
and I'd also point out to councilor Hull
that if she wants to buy it away Now's
the Time to ask for it outline thank you
and it specifically it goes into the
details about the decibel ratings
um its comparison against
established
decibel levels for developments adjacent
to residential areas
so between
5.4.2 and 5.4.7 is quite comprehensive
thank you chairman thank you very much
I sort of accept that and I'm sure Mr
Johnson's going to direct me to where
that's covered off in 32 uh conditions
um so um perhaps you might like to do
that because whilst it might be in The
Narrative of the report
um it really has to be within the
conditions and and look I've looked
through twice and I couldn't see it in
the proposed conditions but I'll be
putting my comfort zone by you right now
I hope
thank you Joe I just wanted to just add
that the what's in the narrative has
come from part of the documents which is
persuade of material that if members of
minded to support this application the
development would have to be carried out
in accordance with thank you chairman
thank you very much Mr Johnson Council
Hull please
thank you very much
um
uh taking the advice of councilor fluka
are you sure okay
um this Bridal path if we could have one
that'd be really we'd be really grateful
on the outline planning thank you I
think it's a yeah although it's a
comment from the floor is the industrial
site but it's still a very valid point
to make and it's in a very beautiful
part of the countryside so I think about
the issue is valid um
and I think given I hear what you're
saying the nature of the site and the
use I don't think it would meet the
requirements um for planning conditions
or
um seal tests because it needs to be
reasonably related to the development
and and Bridal waves wouldn't be related
to an employment use but you could ride
on a horse to work and that's a very
great name that's all serious this is a
very Green Way of working you know so
okay
thank you okay thank you Miss herner's
point though um Council Swain please yes
thanks yeah I mean as this is an outline
um permission is it possible to put in a
condition about
um should we say maximizing the
um the verbal use of solar panels
and perhaps TV glazing thank you
I think it would be something to come
forward at Reserve methods and once
we've got now the layout and the the
buildings and how they could be
incorporated on there because at the
moment we don't have any buildings that
we know
where they was facing what not
counsel her please
um thank you chairman
um I'll I will be brief but I think
really this application ticks all the
boxes to me
um I think that you've got uh the uh
Progressive building as and when it's
required when I look at the plan like
that that's more that's more of a garden
suburb than the suburbs that we're
building
so I so so I really think I really think
that enough has been said about this and
I would urge members to uh to support
this application
well we actually have um members we have
had a proposal to accept that was made
by councilor white and that was secular
by councilor Durham
um so we've put that to the vote by sent
or agreed and unanimously agreed thank
you very much indeed Berner thank you
members we now move on to agenda item
seven which is excuse me Members which
is reference number two two zero zero
eight four zero slash f-u-l-m slash oval
Park Northwest plot Hatfield Road
Langford which is found on your agenda
papers 83 to 128 and again miss herner
if you'd like to present the report
thank you thank you chairman this this
application is a full application sorry
members could we just have a bit of
order please thank you this is a full
application for the erection of an
employment building for through generous
purposes with car parking servicing and
Landscaping areas and just to note
whilst The Proposal itself isn't a
personal permission because the nature
of it being a super generous use and it
is actually specific to the applicants
and their requirements um because it
will involved salt processing packaging
collection there's um Hospitality areas
a um development kitchen and aspects
like that so actually if anybody else
has ever to move into the site that
would need a new permission to be able
to be adapted into the way they want so
yeah as I say not a personal permission
per se but
would be protected in that sense
and so we are now talking about this
area of the site here so that's to um
use the car parking earlier that would
end that was facilitated earlier by the
agreement to approve this application
for car parking there's some grade two
listed buildings
um within this part of the site so you
have Beavis Hall and BB's Halls Barn
and so the same Highway upgrades that
were proposed as part of the last
application also apply to this
application so the Improvement of the
lay buyers the footway link and members
of the speed limit and the enhancements
of the existing bus service
the The Proposal itself will employ a 75
staff
and he's just an aerial photo so you can
see
um existing boundary presentation here
between the listed building and the
application site
and the location of block plan
and then just a more zoomed in version
again of the layout
so this is the
tree impacts
um
so a few trees to be removed
um just to facilitate the development
but again they're largely considered to
be of low quality and low immunity value
the surface water management strategy
which follows a similar proposal to what
we've seen previously and sorry I should
have mentioned as well if I'll go back
there's an extension proposed to the
parking area and that already exists to
just facilitate more parking within the
site
so here we have the elevations of the
buildings this is the main elevation
that will front the oval and so previous
inspector had commented on the
need to retain the oval and what that
brings to the character of the site
to the other elevations
so we have um a lot of height variation
to
um trying to break up the mess and we've
also as part of the pre-application
process discussed the materials and to
be able to use this gradient clad in
um so rather than just a big stock
Warehouse they can build in and you'll
have a gradient of um
greens are shown
so yeah we've also got a modern sort of
Frontage so it it's a commercial in
appearance but I think with um modern
Twist on it so here we have the CGI of
the front of the building so you can see
a lot of glazing to break up that bulk
as well and then just to see Joy of how
it relates to the the oval form and you
can see some car parking as well
so we have some roof plans
the ground floor so the warehouse and
production elements and then the
um welfare area says canteen the
development kitchen and some meeting
rooms
and the first floor plan so a mezzanine
area and then some more office
facilities
and then second floor more welfare
um facilities and mezzanine oh sorry a
Terrace area
and then there's just a closer look at
the floor plan so close it wasn't clear
on those plans
so site access which I'm sure you're
well rehearsing by now
and it's a site photos so
um this is the existing car parking area
and then this is looking back towards
the listed building to take you
back to the location plan
um to sort of standing looking across
the site in an awfully Direction
and then yes some existing vegetation
you can see
here in this place I was here
and this this is the
Northern boundary of the site and then
this is looking back through the trees
um towards the employment building that
exists and the boundary of Hatfield Road
here and the site access roadway to the
development would be
on this parcel of land here
so here you can see the listed building
is sighted behind here and Hatfield Road
and then again just another view of
where the listed building would be
across the site so the application
building would be in here
so this is a Viewpoint from um Hatfield
Road itself so this is the listed barn
and they're listed Wenham and then the
neighboring property
Viewpoint from the site access looking
across where the development would be
looking in a Northern Direction a longer
Viewpoint so
um this is the existing employment
building you can see here
again another Long Range View coming in
from the West
more West Olivier
and then say viewpoints 23 22 and 23
have been highlighted in the lvia to be
the most important Viewpoint with the
where the greatest degree of harm would
be
um but there is it's dated there's a lot
of vegetation and screen in the
development and
um over time once the proposed
vegetation matures as well it's
considered that the impact would be
reduced to a moderate adverse effect
foreign
would have a moderate level on the less
than substantial scale of harm to the
listed building and a low level
of harm to the conservation area so
again we apply the plan imbalance
the economic and social benefits however
again are considered to substantially
outweigh the harm and due to the
provision of the employment and the
highways upgrades which both have
significant social and environmental
benefits as I've said there will be 70
foot five full-time employ full-time
employees promotion of the modern brand
a growth in the food sector highly
trained and skilled employees and
traction of inward investment
um and then what I've said earlier about
being allocated land and there might be
an impact on the loss of other land uses
and the improvements to the
local transport Network and the use of
previously developed land
there is of course some disadvantages
that come with the increasing vehicle
movements
um but the parking is considered to be
suitable based on the evidence in the
staff surveys and the implementation of
the workplace travel plan and the
highway upgrades and the over provision
of cycle spaces
uh we can also restrict the hours of use
to protect residential immunity
um whilst the modern salt use itself
will actually involves shift work the
actual nighttime vehicle movements are
limited to 30 movements and there was no
concerns raising the noise impact
assessment in regards to that
and there's also
I should have mentioned earlier an
acoustic barrier
um proposed along this boundary to
protect any noise traveling to the
closest noise receptors of the
residential dwellings here
and yeah so overall applying the
planning balance offices of the view
that the economic and social benefits
will substantially outweigh the harm on
the list of building and the principle
of development is acceptable and the
um Parkland character of the site in
itself were being maintained so
record of approval thank you chairman
thank you very much thank you okay we
have a public speaker again Mr Davey
um thank you again
um
I think everyone knows more than Salt
I've been in the town for many many
years and he exports to over 60
countries and there's production
facilities at goldhanger and in the town
and it's current headquarters and
distribution facilities are at White
Hill
the companies it's on an ambitious
grocer trajectory and he's currently
doubling its production of gold hanger
and it needs to headquarters research
and development packing and distribution
distribution facilities to match
the company wants to stay in the
district and after searching for a
number of years it's identified oval
Park the place where it wants to be
should members resolve to Grant consent
today it will buy the land and it will
develop the plot itself it's agreed the
unilateral undertaking with the county
and it's already committed significant
sums working beyond the project beyond
the planning stage
so should members Grant consent today or
resolve to Grant you'd host be on site
in the uh Autumn early winter of this
year
scheme Architects have designed an
attractive Sustainable Building they
will sit comfortably within oval Park
and complement the adjacent CML and
Technic buildings uh just on the
renewable energy I can confirm there's a
preamp statement submitted with all
three applications which covered covers
renewable energy regeneration site and
there will be solar panels or ground
Source heat pumps or the that kind of
development within the scheme
um the majority of existing boundary
Landscaping will be retained it's a
large site so all surface water drainage
and ecology issues can be dealt with in
the plot
Highway and Access Transportation has
been resolved to County highways in your
offices uh
um satisfaction there will be some minor
harm to the setting of Heritage assets
but as your officer said we think
they're outweighed by the benefits and
the economic benefits of the scheme it's
also relevant the consent already exists
to develop this part of the site which
can still be enacted so modern talk
hopes that you'll support the proposals
and it can bring new headquarters office
to this site and it can continue to grow
in the district thank you thank you very
much indeed
um first speaker please is a councilor
white
um thank you Mr chairman um just a
replay of everything I said before the
meeting got adjourned I think this is an
application we need I'm really pleased
they're doing all the solar the
underground Source heat pumps and
everything else
um I hope to see all the car charging
points because I've got an electric cars
so that's something that we need to see
more of and um I propose that we accept
this
recommendation to approve Thank You
seconded by cancer Thompson data we can
only do two Council Fluker please yeah
thank you chairman um
can you put up the um the rendering the
proposed design yeah
I mean chairman I'm I'm glad in some
ways that
um
um Peter Eisman from the um the Advent
Garden movement didn't bring this design
forward because I'm sure it would have
been an assault seller but I mean this
fits in perfectly with oval Park and and
German you know I support the proposal
to to to approve this chairman and I
think you know
um unless anybody's got to say anything
that's uh contrary to this we we should
take the vote and move on thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor
fluka we've got a couple of other
speakers before we do move to the vote
Council Edwards and then councilor Swain
please
yes thank you chairman um I do also
support this but I have one question
um which might be relevant or not
bearing in mind there's no facilities in
the in the area in terms of shops and
such like and bearing in mind the
population of the working population is
I believe over 200
are the on page
85 three point
one six are the canteen facilities open
to all the companies on the site or just
sort more and sword thank you
of course
yeah so um yeah each application is in
it I guess it'd be to the applicant
whether they open the doors but each
application does have its own welfare
facilities
Council Swain please oh yes thank you
chairman
um I noticed it says um about the noise
that the concentrated on the car park
here and so on
um can you establish
um will it be 24-hour working of any
noisy machinery
in the plant
thank you councilor Swain
so um this is something but there's a
condition to ensure that any
um
X I think it's external noise doesn't
exceed the 40 decibels to make sure that
any
um machine noise doesn't impact on day
or night and the we've got also got a
condition to agree working hours so that
would be something that would be within
our control
councilor Stevens please
thank you chair I think people shouldn't
misconstrue questions as being against
something but it is just a question
um in the first application the one for
the car parts night I noticed that under
the um internal consultees it said waste
they hadn't responded well okay it's car
park
but there's no such comment against that
against waste here it doesn't say
whether they've responded or not it
doesn't even say that waste exists
there will be waste generated by a new
building full of employees and I'm just
curious why there isn't a comment from
the waste department please or if you
can make a comment on that thank you
thank you Council Stevens I'm sorry
there um has been no comment from the
waste team on any of these applications
the um
yeah it's I can't so I'm trying to think
we have a condition for you Mrs Johnson
and he looked like he was gonna say
something
no I'm just saying we waste haven't
commented um but we can
agree waste from the site as part of
conditions yeah um
I mean it would be standard for them to
have to enter into a waste contract as a
commercial operator
um so there are there are controls um
outside
um of planning that could satisfy that
so I'm rest assured that waste can be as
part of a normal contract commercial
contract agreement can be satisfied
thank you chairman thank you very much
indeed uh councilor Darren please
I was just going to say exactly what Mr
Johnson has said I mean it the fact that
there's no comment from our waste
department is irrelevant because the
commercial waste isn't dealt with by
this Authority and each operator would
need their own commercial waste
agreement and anything they're putting
in it would be subject to license from
the environment agency should there be
something yeah quite correct okay
members thank you very much indeed um we
have uh uh recommendation to approve
which has been proposed by councilor
white and second by councilor Thompson
and the members agree with this person
okay that Bernadette's agreed and passed
by a cent thank you we now thank you
very much we now move on to agenda item
eight members which is reference
2200858 slash f-u-l-m slash and it's no
surprise oval Park Southern plot
Hatfield Road Langford this can be found
on pages 129 to 172 of your agenda packs
and again it's maternity present the
report thank you thank you chairman this
is another full application for a
deployment building with a three
generous use class and with car parking
servicing and Landscaping areas and with
the previous application so it's too
generous whilst it's not a personal
permission it is specific to the
applicants
to the
um
proposal would result in the employment
of 225 staff members the same highways
upgrades that have applied to the
previous last two previous applications
uh also relevant to this the development
includes offices research and
development facilities a glaze showcase
and restoration work stops for a
workshop for their classic car Division
and Welfare facilities for the staff
so we have the wider landscape master
plan shown again so it's this area of
the site and so car parking to be
screened to the rear of the building
and
um just again to give you the context of
the site so this part of the site is
more open with some vegetation to the
rear
so we have the location and block plan
again
and they're more zoomed in layout plan
so again the development would front
oval Park retaining that as a central
feature within the site
and the cycle parking you can see here
and also as with the other applications
disabled and electric charging Bay is
also provided
see the tree the areas highlighted in
red and the groups of trees highlighted
and read to be removed and the
individual trees and again as with the
other applications the landscape the
immunity impacts are considered minor
and the trees aren't considered to be of
great quality
so surface water management strategy
again permeable Paving where possible
and with a swells the front of the site
so we've got elevation so you can see
that this references and the previous
application as well so the two buildings
will Tire well with each other and well
into the wider site and similar
materials use of glazing to break up the
expense of
um particularly on this elevation the
Walling so just to give you some context
that would be this elevation here so
anyone traveling along the excess Road
here particularly into the business park
wouldn't be greeted with just a
expensive Warehouse there would be
interesting features
and then you have the glazed car
showcase as well front in the oval to
provide a bit of interest in sight and
variation in Heights
so CGI just showing this
and another angle
Reef plans
ground floor plan so we've got the
workshop with the restoration workshop
with the glaze showcase here office of
welfare facilities and the production
Workshop
then on the second floor
um more office and Welfare with the
mezzanine area to the workshop
and then just a section through the
workshop
the axis
the existing car park
um I don't know if I mentioned to the
car park to the Eastern side of the
existing employment building would serve
this application is what it is so let me
roll back of it
yeah so these there's proposed car
parking in here as well as well as
um the use of the existing car park that
currently serves the CML building
and then just looking east across the
site back towards the oval and the
existing employment use and the access
road
Viewpoint a lot along the distance
Viewpoint looking North
one from Alton Lane
I was in line again
looking Northeast sorry Northwest
then you just see the employment
building here from
so they decide I'll actually be from
this Viewpoint screen behind the
existing employment building there
and then um as with the previous
application viewpoints 22 and 23
um are considered to be the most
impacted on but this building
particularly would be screened by the
mold and salt building and the the
existing employment building
um so this proposal won't cause any harm
to the listed building due to the
intervening vegetation in the distance
from those buildings but the planning
balance again applies because of the
impacts on the Conservation Area
the economic and social benefits are
much the same as what I've repeated
before and this site literally as the
largest number of employees
there's um the same disadvantages prior
to the vehicle movements but all ecology
matters have been addressed parking is
considered suitable and we can secure
all the highway upgrades by section 106.
um yeah other than what I've repeated
earlier I don't think there's anything
else to add so this application is
recommended for approval thank you thank
you very much indeed Devin um again we
have one public participant Mr
not yet not until debate's been done Mr
Davey please
uh thank you again um final time
um thank you member this application is
for technique it actually started in
Malden but it I had to move out to
witton to find suitable premises but it
now wants to come back into the district
it designs Engineers manufacturers tests
and supplies low volume bespoke high-end
Vehicle Systems for likes of
Mercedes-Benz McLaren Aston Martin Range
Rover Telsa Porsche Bentley you sit in
one of those cars and what you touch
will be manufactured by technique
it utilizes Cutting Edge technology and
production techniques and has
experienced 25 year-on-year growth and
it needs new premises if it's to
continue to grow
the company's had long-standing links
with local schools and higher education
establishments including University of
Essex
culture Institute Cranfield University
and the University of East Anglia it's
got a large graduate and Apprenticeship
Training scheme and all the
apprenticeships that are from local
schools and extensive upskilling and
retraining program operated in
partnership with UEA uh to for workers
seeking to retrain and relocate and it
will bring 200 high-tech well-paid jobs
into the district
as with modern salt Technic will buy and
develop the site itself to house its
Administration research development
design and production functions
boundary Landscaping will be retained
and enhanced and the the building will
meet the council's sustainability and
construction standards
the application is self-contained in at
once the CML car park has been replaced
it fully addresses within the red line
all archaeological Heritage ecology
transport access and drainage issues and
if technique is the first project on
site it is the one that will deliver the
sustainable transport improvements so
technique hopes that as with the other
applications members can support this
proposal and allow it to come back into
the district thank you thank you
so no we're not going to do that as yet
members thank you very much indeed
um we have some members of Raisin
expression to speak so I'll take those
first and then we'll move to that
councilor white please thank you Mr
chairman um well that's there again it's
a business that we need in the districts
the business want to support and I have
to say I hope if we're all re-elected
um that when these businesses are up and
running we certainly get to have a look
around some of these businesses because
to me they sound really exciting and I'm
really proud to have them coming into
the Malden District I support them 100
and because of that I'd like to propose
that we agree the officer's
recommendation to approve this
application thank you very much I think
actually Council Seattle did make a
proposal so I've actually noted that
cats are simply propose that so but you
get circumstances
yeah we was a little bit at premature
our councilor stilts please
it's just a quick question really on
condition five you talk about the will
and underbody washing facilities can you
tell me how that water will be collected
whether that is going to go to runoff
drain water or whether it is going to be
reused cleaned
um so that it doesn't contaminate the
area
so that will be something that would be
agreed as part of the construction
management plan when that comes in but
it would be ensured that it wouldn't
cause any contamination
thank you very much members I've had the
proposal for recommendation by councilor
settle and seconded by councilor white
um does that by Ascent agreed members
that's agreed thank you let me move on
to item number nine members any items of
business that I decided are Urgent there
are a couple one is yeah it's easy
tigers
and they're really quick it's just an
expression of thanks for the officers
reports and the quality of those reports
because this is a very important
application so thank you to the officers
and those behind the scenes also to it
for getting us back up and going because
my my impression was to close the
meeting which I didn't want to do but
for democracy and transparency it's
important that we had that and just
thank all members in attendance and all
members of the public and the agent for
your patience well we had that 10 to
wake up members are now close this
meeting thank you at 2120. thank you
travel home safely
huh